hola qué tal muy buen día según el
reciente balance que ofreció el
presidente el consejo nacional electoral
apenas el
76% de las mesas de votación de los
centros de votación estaban operativos
nosotros hicimos un recorrido por el
municipio sucre venimos de un centro de
votación que no tenía luz desde las 3 de
la mañana y ni siquiera había abierto
una de sus mesas esto se puede replicar
en algunos otros sitios donde no han
logrado instalar e iniciar el proceso de
votación pese a que se tenía previsto
iniciar a las 6 de la mañana --hora
local-- en estos momentos ya pasan las 8
de la mañana también hemos visto poca
afluencia de ciudadanos en los centros
de votación que existen abiertos también
vale destacar que el proceso es bastante
rápido los ciudadanos ingresan se
verifican en esos listados que ven a mis
espaldas entran se demorarán a un par de
minutos y luego ya salen de los centros
de votación
hemos visto sí bastantes filas en las
estaciones de servicio para surtir
gasolina y poca circulación de vehículos
y transporte público en la zona
daniela cuál es la percepción de los
venezolanos sobre estas elecciones
las opiniones están divididas tal cual
como la oposición hay ciudadanos que
consideran que no deben quedarse en su
casa que deben ejercer su derecho al
voto si quieren un cambio en el país
también está la base del chavismo que
llama a votar para defender la
revolución para defender el gobierno de
nicolás maduro y condenar las sanciones
pues ese es el discurso del gobierno lo
trascendental de estas elecciones sería
ver cómo queda el mapa de venezuela pero
también cómo se reorganiza la oposición
que no participaba tal y como lo decías
desde el año 2017 y también esto tendrá
un impacto en el diálogo que se lleva a
cabo en méxico entre oposición y
gobierno buscando también mejores
garantías para unos eventuales comicios
presidenciales este proceso de votación
que debió haber rentado en su totalidad
a las 6 de la mañana --hora local--
terminaría a las 6 de la tarde -hora
local- siempre y cuando no haya
electores en cola de lo contrario sería
hasta que el último votante pueda
ejercer su derecho posteriormente se
esperaría los balances del consejo
nacional electoral la misión de
observación de la unión europea está
recorriendo el país para posteriormente
emitir un informe
23 de noviembre